1994 naissance de l'espace rambouillet
deux ans après avoir obtenu la direction
du parc animalier des yvelines philippe
bertschy le transforme le réinvente 2013
il quitte la direction pour poursuivre
sa carrière professionnelle
bonsoir fil bell chine le chiffre de
cette édition vous est dédié 19-19 c'est
le nombre d'années que vous avez passées
à la tête de l'espace rambouillet le
chiffre de cette édition qui s'affichait
ce que vous partez avec regret presque
vingt ans bon avec des regrets non mais
avec évidemment beaucoup d'émotion parce
qu'on reste pas un poste quel qu'il soit
longtemps comme ça sans émotion de
laisser aussi certain nombre de
personnes de laisser des souvenirs de
l'essai plein de choses mais partir
alors finalement au bois parce qu'à un
moment faut bien parti parce que voilà
dans une vie professionnelle
quelquefois faut savoir partir aussi et
donc j'avais envie de vivre d'autres
aventures forestière voilages et j'étais
en forêt avant de venir à l'espace
rambouillet et puis le parcours se
termine vous avez qui poursuit pendant
ces termes et pour l'espace en ligne et
ça me manque c'est en tout cas puisque
vous travaillez maintenant au siège de
l'office national rien voilà la carrière
qui se poursuit pour vous en tout cas on
va revenir sur la genèse de ce projet et
sur la création de cet espace
rambouillet vous l'avez créant 94 ne
vous êtes arrivants 92 y avait déjà un
parc animalier même un espace
rambouillet je n'ai pas créé tout seul
évidemment il ya toute une équipe qui a
travaillé il existait un parc animalier
qui s'appelait le parc animés des
yvelines qui avait été créée en 1972 est
évidemment le service de l'office
national des forêts avait
souhait de le voir évoluer c'est comme
ça que nous avons été mis en contact
avec notamment des personnes qui avaient
des rapaces et qui souhaitait installer
une voilerie de rapaces au sein de
l'espace rambouillet et de cette idée
est née l'espace en milliers aujourd'hui
c'est 250 hectares laisse pas sans
mouiller soir à mal les rapa
s'empressèrent les lions le cerf les
biches les aurochs et puis l'odyssée
verte
et puis tout récemment beaucoup de
visiteurs n'auront pas encore vu un
bâtiment d'accueil tout neuf en bois
avec une chaufferie bois qui va les
accueillir dans de meilleures conditions
l'espace rambouillet vous a permis de
montrer quoi que la forêt était vivante
notablement et ben c'est peut-être la
meilleure satisfaction que toute
personnelle de l'espace rambouillet peut
avoir au bout de ces années c'est
d'avoir accueilli beaucoup de visiteurs
et d'avoir passé avec l'office national
des forêts un message pour mieux
connaître mieux comprendre mieux
protéger aussi la forêt s'il ya une
satisfaction à avoir c'est celle d'avoir
vu passer cinquante mille enfants qui
viennent chaque année donc on travaille
beaucoup avec l'éducation nationale
évidemment la spa sanglier c'est un lieu
de découverte de la forêt des animaux
des grandes ondes et en asie les serres
les biches mais les petits il suffit de
lever quelques feuilles mortes on à la
microfaune du sol donc c'est surtout ça
qui est important pour les élèves de
développer un outil qui va permettre de
mieux comprendre la forêt et ce ne sont
que des spécialistes qui interviennent
et qui échangent avec les enfants les
plus jeunes vous parliez des échanges
dans le cadre scolaire mais qui
intervient auprès de ses enfants alors
évidemment il ya des spécialistes où il
ya des animateurs qui connaissent très
bien la nature la forêt qui vont
accueillir les visiteurs qui vont
accompagner les groupes on va travailler
avec eux il ya des classes qui viennent
trois fois au cours de la même année
scolaire donc il ya un vrai une vraie
possibilité de faire une découverte
pédagogique lors de sorties scolaires à
l'espace rambouillet vous allez
forcément gardé un oeil sur le travail
qui sera fait par tu repars votre
successeur oui bien sûr je veux tourner
match n'a pas complètement la salle
j'espère que c'est bien aussi qui est du
changement pour les gens qui restent
parce que il ya des gens qui sont là
depuis longtemps donc là l'année 2013 va
se dérouler sans problème
rendez vous le dimanche 17 mars et un
premier événement avec une vente de
plants darbo folha qui est un arbre et
homme exceptionnel de l'est de l'office
national des forêts donc là il y aura
une collection de plantes originales et
puis tous les événements sont déjà
programmées pour 2013 donc vous êtes
parti en laissant un calendrier déjà
tout aimerait je suis pas tout seul
heureusement c'est pas moi qui fait tout
il ya tout un ensemble de personnes
les hôtesses d'accueil les animateurs
les fauconniers qui sont là depuis
longtemps qui connaissent bien leur
métier
et puis les plus récemment on a vu
l'odyssée verte avec les opérateurs de
l'odyssée verte aussi qui va qui va
réouvrir jeu les votants avec le beau
temps va revenir ce sera la découverte
de cette saison printanière va faire une
petite pause on va poser la question aux
yvelinois est traditionnellement le
micro-trottoir de cette édition est
consacrée à l'espace rambouillet l
espace ont brouillé est ce que vous le
connaissez et quand pensez vous laisse
pas son boulot ça me dit rien du tout ça
pour être un lieu à rambouillet l'espace
culturel quelque chose qui est en lien
avec la ferme les animaux il y avait des
gros lapin voilà apparemment c'était
intéressant des moutons ou si il me
semble voilà oui ça l'est beaucoup plus
à ma fille de noms mais je ne suis
jamais allé à l'espace rambouillet c'est
une faune sauvage où il ya les aigles
et des faucons si je crois des sangliers
et c'est bien pour les enfants il ya des
bonnes balades à faire là pas de souci
oui je le connais je le trouve très
agréable c'est déjà là avec mes enfants
c'est vraiment un très bel endroit et je
le conseille à tout le monde un espace
apprécié pour ceux qui le connaissent
oui voilà vous êtes satisfait du de
laura obtenu par l'espace rambouillet au
delà de justement du cadre de
rambouillet est là on est sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines on est un petit peu plus loin
que que la forêt que cet espace
rambouillet mais on le connaît malgré
tout oui alors c'est très difficile de
faire la publicité de toute façon on n'a
pas les moyens d'investir les campagnes
d'affichage multiples et variées parce
que ça coûte très cher et puis on
préfère consacrer nos moyens financiers
à d'autres choses
ce qui est intéressant de voir c'est que
il ya les gens qui viennent sont souvent
relativement content et ce qui marche
bien c'est le bouche à oreille donc on
voit il y en a plein qui ne sont pas
venus encore donc ça laisse beaucoup de
perspectives mais c'est aussi un lieu
qui doit qui doit rester avec des
fréquentations correct sinon si si à
trop de gens qui viennent à la fois
facile et il faut venir au mois une fois
découvrir l'espace rambouillet
effectivement comme le dit votre micro
trottoir cette précision vous n'avez pas
de moutons non pour répondre à la micro
trottoir ce n'est pas l'espace
rambouillet peut-être manière à boudy et
quand même identifié autour de l'animal
que son père duval sauvage où l'animal
domestique
en forêt ou dans la ferme on est dans
typhi beaucoup la région de rambouillet
comme une terre animal et comment vous
l'avez développer justement ce parc on
parlait de la fréquentation de la
publicité difficile à faire je lisais
avant que vous veniez sur ce plateau une
interview que vous aviez réalisé avec
nos confrères de l'écho républicain vous
avez ouvert une page minitel alors ça
c'était le tout début parce que je vais
lancer sur toutes les technologies et
imaginables il le parc était encore
moins connu est effectivement c'était la
première j'avais un 35 15 15 le spasfon
ben parce que rambouillet n'avais pas
trop de caractère
voilà donc c'était 36 15 espace tomber
effectivement c'était le premier outil
de communication qu'on avait et c'était
c'était très intéressant quoi donc d'un
seul coup on était un petit peu plus
connu puis quand on tapait rambouillet
on était dans la liste des sites dans
les yvelines en ile-de-france donc voilà
ça c'étaient les bonnes a précisé mattel
maintenant voilà entre les facebook et
twitter on pense que l'espacement
bouillet bertoua twitter pour l'espace
rambouillet vous n'avez pas encore une
telle mission pour votre succès ce lien
non seulement on peut se développer que
nos logis quels sont les projets qu'il
reste à développer justement sur cet
espace rambouillet aujourd'hui alors il
ya plein de choses à voir un on a
développé
l'odyssée verte qui est un sentier
suspendus dans les arbres et puis autour
de d'exposition sur l'odyssée verte on a
parlé des champignons des chauves-souris
d'un certain nombre de choses dont il ya
beaucoup de thématiques de thématiques
autour de l'eau de thématiques autour de
la forêt le thème des thématiques autour
des des insectes ou autre il ya
énormément de choses qui sont encore qui
doivent être faites évidemment autour de
la forêt de l'écosystème forestier est
ce que l'avenir aujourd'hui pour
l'espace en moyen c'est de devenir un
parc d'attraction non tout à l'heure
vous disiez ne faut pas une
fréquentation trop trop grandes mais
pour autant vous avez créé
l'accrobranche par exemple à s'éloigner
un petit peu plus l'idée des missions de
alors il faut en avoir les fruits que ce
soit intéressant parce que les gens ils
le disent ils ont envie qu'il y ait ce
que on n'utilise pas le terme en main
terme et des attractions on va dire et
l'odyssée verte en fait en fait partie
les gens aiment ça mais il faut que ça
reste compatible avec le milieu naturel
parce que les gens aiment ça aussi je
pense qu'un par beaucoup trop aménagé
saurait peut-être un petit peu moins
bien perçus donc c'est une alchimie qui
est assez difficile à trouver entre des
gens qui veulent quelque chose de nature
mais quelque chose d' aménager quelque
temps même
donc voilà la petite petit curseur à m
c'est pas toujours facile de le trouver
s'il y avait un mot pour qualifier ces
19 années pour conclure je crois que
c'est une belle aventure c'est une belle
aventure où ont participé des dizaines
de personnes y en a qui sont encore là
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont accueillir les
visiteurs de nouvelles personnes vont
venir donc de nouvelles énergies et
c'est très bien
je pense que oui on a participé à notre
petite échelle à l'éducation à
l'environnement
peut-être qu'on était un peu précurseur
que l'office a soin de les forêts
étaient précurseurs notamment en 1972
lorsque le parc animalier des yvelines a
ouvert et on voit qu'on est encore
d'actualité autour de ce thème du
développement durable la biodiversité de
la connaissance de la nature il vous
reviendrai pour les 20 ans va
s'embrouiller dès l'année prochaine 2014
l'espace en brière qui tourne une page
une nouvelle page va s'ouvrir mais qui
reste bien ouverts vous pouvez toujours
devenir fauconnier d'ailleurs c'était
une des animations qui existent et qui
relançait encore cette année à partir du
15 mars où pouvait le temps d'une
matinée suivre le travail des
fauconniers juste une précision le nom
de la personne qui vous remplace n'est
pas encore connue il y en aura une oui
mais pour l'instant il intérim
voilà donc tout se passe bien du tout se
passera en juillet merci à vous un film
belge il est revenu sur ce plateau à
nous parler du travail que vous avez
accompli durant ces 19 années à suivre
la chronique de l'environnement julie
rocha soares elle va nous parler
botanique avec son invité les herbes se
mange vous allez le voir elle met déjà
détour par maurepas à la ville accueille
une toute nouvelle résidence étudiante
plus de 180 places pour pallier la
pénurie actuelle de logements étudiants
sur ce chantier à maurepas ont construit
une toute nouvelle résidence étudiante
vendredi dernier ont posé la première
pierre en coulant dans le béton ce
parchemin où est inscrit le nom de jan
palach car cette résidence portera le
nom de cet étudiant tchécoslovaque qui
s'est immolé par le feu en 1969 pour
protester contre l'invasion soviétique
un symbole de liberté destinées aux
futurs locataires d'un point de vue plus
terre à terre ses 183 studio permettront
de combler un manque dans le département
cbre e denis muzet
la ville c'est aussi pour permettre à
des étudiants de la ville et de la
périphérie de se loger c'est pour
répondre aussi à un besoin qui régional
vous savez qu'il manque plus de 10000
logement étudiant en ile de france donc
moore pas voulu s'inscrire dans cette
démarche et répondent à ce besoin
côté pratique les étudiants seront
situés à cinq minutes du centre et de la
gare de la verrière 100 places de
parking seront également créés très
proche de la nationale 10 la résidence
devrait profiter d'un traitement
acoustique pour le bruit le bâtiment se
veut respectueux de l'environnement avec
par exemple des panneaux solaires pour
les besoins en eau chaude
en tout trois mille huit cents mètres
carrés dont une laverie un local vélo et
un espace commun et les constructeurs
ont pensé à une évolution à long terme
du bâtiment les logements étudiants ont
c'est un besoin instantanée et donc de
ce fait même en espérant que ce soit
conservé ainsi c'est quelque chose qui
doit pour être amené à évoluer
différemment par la suite en fonction
utilisation différente l'aspect initial
de l'opération les cloisons sont
utilisés à cette fin là pour pouvoir
ajuster les logements les agrandir
paraître un glissement pour
développement le plus confortable le
joint étudiants étant assez réduit les
cloisons entre les chambres pourront
donc être abattus pour créer des
logements plus grands pour des personnes
âgées ou des familles monoparentales une
possibilité pour le futur mais pour les
années à venir
le bâtiment sera bien réservé aux
étudiants ils sont attendus à la rentrée